Okay, so today we're going to continue
our study of subgame perfect Nash
equilibria
and specifically we're going to look at
multi-stage
something called multi-stage games.
And the key technical tool that we're
going to introduce today is something
called the one-shot deviation principle.
So, I'll go into detail about what this
is later in the class, but it's going to
allow us to compute or to check that a
strategy profile is in fact a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium even in games
that have an infinite horizon.
And using this tool, we're then going to
revisit one of the application we looked
at before, this price haggling game
where you have a buyer and a seller
haggling over what the price is going to
be that they exchange the good. And if
you recall when we first modeled that
game, we had this artificial time at
which that the world ended because we
didn't have the tools to analyze an
infinite horizon game. But now we're
going to apply these techniques to be
able to fully analyze the infinite
horizon version of bargaining.
So, I want to start by saying that what
I did last class was was true but was
maybe a little more subtle and I want to
point out that there's kind of I want to
give kind of a cautionary note about
some of the reasoning we did last class.
So, we looked at games maybe like this.
Let's do this
enter and exit game where we had first
player one chose whether to exit or
enter. If they exited, let's say each
player got 1.5.
And then if they entered, let's say they
played the Boston game. So, player two
moved
and chose Celtics or Red Sox
and then player one moved
and then the payoffs
were
uh let's see
player one let's see two one
one two
zero zero and zero zero.
>> [snorts]
>> And we argued that one equilibrium of
this game
is the equilibrium where
we have XR R.
And we argued that this is a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium.
And let's see how we reasoned about
that.
Well, we said there's two subgames.
There's the entire game and there's the
subgame that starts here. So, the first
step is always to identify our subgames.
And then we said, let's find a Nash
equilibrium within this subgame, within
this smaller subgame. Remember we always
start at the end.
We start with the smaller subgames that
come at the end and we work backwards.
And we know that this subgame is the
standard BOS game that we studied before
and we know that one equilibrium of this
game is that both players go to the Red
Sox game.
So, we filled in that equilibrium.
And then we took a step back. We said,
well, if this is the equilibrium that's
being played in this subgame
then the payoff in this subgame
is going to be one two. We said, if this
subgame is reached, that's what the
payoffs are going to be.
And then we said, if I'm player one,
well, I'm effectively choosing to exit
and get a payoff of 1.5
or to enter and get the payoff in the
Nash equilibrium of this subgame and get
one. So, I'm better off exiting and we
said, great. This is an SPNE.
So, that's true. Everything is correct.
But I want to argue that there's a
little subtlety here.
And the subtlety is that we sort of
skipped a step.
And what we didn't think about is
and I'll say, what about complicated
deviations?
by player one.
What do I mean by this? Well,
we checked that this strategy
constitutes a Nash equilibrium in the
subgame. That's pretty clear.
But we also have to check that this
constitutes an equilibrium in the full
game because part of the definition of
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium is that
the strategy profile must constitute a
Nash equilibrium within every subgame
and the full game is one particular
example of a subgame.
So, what we have to show
is that player one does not have a
profitable deviation in the full game.
Now, what did we actually show?
What we showed is, well, if I'm player
one and I deviate to enter
and then continue the strategy down
here, that won't be profitable.
But when we filled in this subgame and
treated the payoff as one two, we
basically fixed the way that player one
plays in this subgame.
And in principle, player one could
consider a more complicated deviation.
What they could do is they could say,
well, what if I enter the game
and then deviate as well in this subgame
and play differently in this subgame.
How do we know that that's not going to
be profitable? Right? All we checked is
that if they enter and then play as
they're supposed to in the subgame,
that's not profitable. But we haven't
checked what happens if player one
enters and then modifies their behavior
in the subgame.
So, we didn't explicitly check that. I
argue that that's okay, but but why? Why
do we not need to worry about these more
complicated deviations?
Anyone
see why? I think this is kind of a
subtle point, so people are
confused, feel free to ask a question.
Yeah. Is it because we already performed
backward induction on the subgame?
Exactly right. So, what happens in one
of these complicated deviations? We
choose N here, but then instead of
following the play that we are supposed
to use in this subgame, we then sort of
deviate again in this subgame.
But we already know that in this subgame
our play constituted a Nash equilibrium.
So, this
further deviation can't be any better
because it involves suboptimal play
within this subgame given the way the
other player is playing.
So,
it turns out what about these more
complicated deviations, the answer is
they can't be profitable.
And why? Because we know that our
strategy profile already constitutes a
Nash equilibrium within this subgame and
therefore given the way the other player
is playing, we're already doing
optimally in this subgame. So, if I were
to enter and then play suboptimally in
the subgame, that can't make me better
off.
Because of backward induction, I'll say.
And it's quote unquote backward
induction because we can't technically
apply backward induction to this game,
but it's the reasoning of working
backward. So, maybe this is just so
intuitive that everyone kind of already
intuited this. Uh I think it is kind of
intuitive, but I just want to highlight
that
there is kind of a subtlety going on and
in our in class today because we're
going to deal with games that have an
infinite horizon, we have to be even
more careful about this subtlety. Yes.
So, why isn't CC a Nash equilibrium?
Uh I didn't say this is the only subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium. This is one
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
There's also a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium where the players play CC
and the player and and the first player
enters. That's a different subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium. But here I'm
just questioning have we fully verified
that this is a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium and I'm just arguing that it
is, but the verification is a little
more subtle than maybe you might think
at first. Yeah. Any other questions on
this?
Okay.
So, it turns out that
dealing with all these complicated
deviations in really big games can be
tricky and we're now going to study a
class of games where the analysis
becomes pretty simple and this is a
class of games that covers a lot of
applications of interest. And these are
going to be called multi-stage games.
And I want to emphasize that these
possibly have an infinite horizon.
So, what is the definition? What is a
multi-stage game?
Well, it's a game that has multiple
stages. Okay, so let's define what that
means.
So, it's a game where we have stages
maybe zero, one, two
dot dot dot and it could either be
finite, it could either go to T
or
it could go on forever. So, I'm allowing
both of those possibilities.
So, it could be finite
or infinite. Both are allowed.
But what happens in these stages? Well,
there's two uh
key properties of these stages.
So, in each stage
some subset of players are going to move
simultaneously.
Maybe I'll
So,
in each stage
some subset of players move
simultaneously.
And then the other key assumption
is that at the beginning of each stage
everyone observes all the moves that
were made prior to that stage.
So, at the beginning of each stage
all prior moves are observed.
So, sometimes these are called
multi-stage games with observed actions
to emphasize the second point. But I
don't want to use that terminology
because
if we look within a stage, we have
multiple players moving simultaneously.
So at the stage where the players moving
simultaneously, they're not observing
the other players' actions. So uh it's
not actually a game of perfect
information because we have these
simultaneous moves within the game.
Are there any Does anyone remember any
examples of multi-stage games or have
any games that we've studied so far
constitute multi-stage games? Yes. Is
this the one where firms have to like
pick entry and then they pick uh
quantities after they observe the price?
Exactly right. So in that uh Cournot
game with entry costs, that was exactly
a multi-stage game that had two stages.
Remember in the first stage the firms
simultaneously chose whether to enter
the market. That was stage I guess we
can call it stage zero if you want to
start at zero.
And then in the second stage, a subset
of players, namely the firms who had
chosen to enter in the first stage, then
simultaneously chose what quantities to
produce. And we made the critical
assumption
that at the beginning of that second
stage, everyone observed the moves in
the first stage. That is all the firms
observed which subset of firms had
entered in the first stage. And maybe I
should be a little more precise when I
say
some subset of players move
simultaneously, it could be that that
the subset that moves simultaneously
depends on what happened in previous
stages. So if you look at that Cournot
entry game, if firms one and two entered
in the first stage, then firms one and
two play simultaneously in the second
stage. If firms three and four entered
in the first stage, then firms three and
four made choices simultaneously. So
some subset, which maybe I'll say it
could be history dependent.
Where history means what happened in the
previous stages.
Another example actually is this game
here.
So how can we think of this game as a
multi-stage game?
Can you walk me through why
we can think I mean I model it as an
extensive form game, but how can we
think of it as a multi-stage game?
Well, in the first stage or it's always
awkward to say with zero. In the zero
stage, in the initial stage, player one
makes a move.
Player one is a subset of players. It's
a subset of players with just one
player. That's the only player who
moves.
So maybe let's pull this down and look
at this.
So if we want to represent this as a
multi-stage game, this is stage zero.
And in stage zero, the only player who
moves is player one.
Then we can think of this
here as stage one.
Why? Well, remember
technically we said player two moves
first and then player one moves after.
But because player one doesn't observe
the move that player two makes, it's as
if players one and two are moving
simultaneously, right? I could say
player one moves and then player two
moves not observing player one's move.
The order doesn't matter as long as the
players don't observe what the other
player is doing. So effectively, what's
happening in this game is the players
are playing a simultaneous move game
within stage one, and that simultaneous
move game is exactly the Boston game
that we studied.
Now we have to check one more thing. Is
it true that at the beginning of stage
one, the players know what happened in
stage zero?
Yes. If we look at this subgame, both
players know that player one must have
played enter.
Because when I'm
player one here, maybe I don't know
which node I'm at within this
information set, but I certainly know
that I'm on this branch of the tree and
therefore I know what happened in stage
zero. So this is a a special case that
we can think of as example of a
multi-stage game.
So this is quite a a flexible general
class of games and it turns out that
it's very easy in this class of games to
check whether a strategy profile is a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium. And
that's what we're going to go over next.
So the next result is what's called the
one-shot deviation principle.
And maybe it's helpful to first, before
I state the result, describe what I mean
by a one-shot deviation. So what is a
one-shot deviation?
Well, let's suppose a player has some
strategy S
in a multi-stage in the game.
And I want to say what does it mean
for S prime
maybe I'll call this I
for S prime to be a one-shot deviation
from S.
Well,
in principle I could deviate from SI in
a very
complicated way.
There's many, many different histories
in the game. The game's really
complicated.
Uh I could make a lot of different
deviations. A one-shot deviation means I
only deviate once or more precisely, I
only deviate at one history or one
contingency, right? So in in multi-stage
games,
we often refer to information sets as
histories because whenever a player is
is called upon to to play in a
multi-stage game, whatever stage it's
in, what they know is exactly what
happened in all the previous stages. So
their information set is a history of
play in all previous stages.
So uh a one-shot deviation from SI if
what do we want to say?
We want to say SI prime
of H is not equal to SI of H
at
one history H.
But SI prime of H
equals SI of H
prime prime at all other histories
H prime.
So remember a strategy is a complete
contingent plan.
It says how player I is going to play at
every history or every contingency at
which they're asked to move.
So when I compare two strategies, I can
ask how different are these strategies?
At how many histories do these
strategies prescribe different behavior?
And we say that SI prime is a one-shot
deviation from SI if there's exactly one
history at which they prescribe
different behavior.
And then at all the other histories,
they prescribe exactly the same
behavior.
Okay?
But we have to be
really, really careful about what this
means at one history.
So even if I
modify my strategy at a single history,
it could mean that play changes at many
histories. So let's go back to our
example of the Cournot game to
understand what this means.
Suppose we have a player who in the
first stage was not supposed to enter
the game.
Or they weren't entering the game. And
now they contemplate a one-shot
deviation. So let's say firm I
deviates
to enter
at the initial history.
So
previously, the firm was not entering at
this initial history at the beginning of
the game. Now they enter. They're only
This is a one-shot deviation. They're
only changing their uh strategy
at that initial history.
But now, because they've entered at that
initial history,
now the way everyone plays in the second
period becomes quite different. So even
though if the firm is deviating at a
single history, it changes play at all
subsequent histories.
Why? Well, now a different firm, a
different number of firms have entered
the game. So the quantities that every
firm is going to produce in the second
period has now changed. Because the
quantities that they produce depend upon
how many firms enter.
So even if the deviation only changes
behavior at one history,
that then changes which future histories
we reach and therefore can change a lot
of things in the game.
Um
and we'll see that
uh
a bit later.
All right.
So now that we've defined what a
one-shot deviation is, we can actually
Let me give a little more notation.
We've said SI prime is a one-shot
deviation from SI. We can be a little
more precise. If SI prime differs from
SI at precisely the history H, we can
call this a one-shot deviation at H,
right? It's a devi- it's a one-shot
deviation where the the the strategy
specifies different play precisely at H.
So we'll maybe say a one-shot deviation
from SI
and maybe we'll add at H if you want to
be more precise about which history
player I is deviating at.
Okay.
So now I think the final ingredient we
need before we can state the one-shot
deviation principle for multi-stage
games is to keep track of well
what are the subgames
of a multi-stage game?
Remember that's always the first step
when you want to try to
identify or solve for a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium. You have to say what
is what's the set of subgames. Any
thoughts on this? What are the subgames
going to be?
Remember to find subgames you just have
to find nodes in the game that can start
a subgame.
So, what are the
set of possible subgames in this
multi-stage game? And it may be helpful
to think we know we studied this Cournot
entry game on Tuesday. That was a
multi-stage game and we identified the
subgames of that game. So, that might
guide you about what the subgames are in
this game.
Well, let's go through step by step.
What about in stage zero?
How many subgames are there that start
in stage zero?
There's just one, the entire game,
right? We start in stage zero, nothing
has happened so far.
So, this is just the whole game.
What about in stage one?
How many subgames start in stage one?
Remember in the Cournot game, we had a
subgame associated with every subset of
firms that could enter in the previous
stage. And it's going to be the same
idea here that in stage one every
history of play in stage zero is going
to initiate a new subgame starting in
stage one.
So,
stage one we have a subgame
for each
stage zero history.
That is however people played in stage
zero, we all know that's how people
played because we observe it and now we
have a subgame starting at that history
of play from here on from here onwards.
Right?
What about in stage two?
Maybe I'll call this H
zero. Where H zero says how people
played
in stage zero. What about in stage two?
How many subgames do we have in stage
two? Now it's getting a little more
complicated.
Well, what do we know in stage two?
We know how people played in in stage
zero and we know how people played in
stage one. So, any history of play in
stage zero and in stage one is going to
start a subgame in stage two. So, now we
have this for each maybe I'll say
history
maybe I'll call it H zero H one
that says this is how we played in stage
zero, this is how we played in stage one
and now we're going to move on to stage
two. And in general we're going to see
that in stage T
we're going to have a much more
complicated history
H zero H one
up to H T minus one.
So, at stage T we know how everyone
played up to stage T minus one
and since we know that that's going to
start a new gate a new subgame from
stage T onward.
So, we see there's going to be a lot of
histories.
Um
and
it's going to be helpful we'll just use
a generic term history to mean a history
at any point. So, it could be a history
here that just says how we played in H
zero. It could be a history here that
says how we played in zero and one. It
could be a history here how we played up
up in here. But we'll look at all those
together we'll just look at arbitrary
we'll call something a history if it's a
history at any stage.
So, what are the subgames of a
multi-stage game? They are
described by
the histories of the game.
So, we have the
maybe I'll call it the we have an H
subgame
for every history H.
So, give me a history H.
It could be
a history like this, it could be a
history like this, it could be a history
like this. That's going to start a
subgame from here on out. And conversely
any subgame is exactly going to have
this form.
Right? So, we have an an association
between the subgames of a multi-stage
game and the histories of play in the
game.
Just so we can make this concrete.
In this example
we had one subgame starting in stage
zero
which was the subgame following the null
history where nothing had happened.
And then we actually had one subgame
starting in stage one following the
single history N. And that was the only
possible history at which we were called
to play in stage one.
So, that's sort of how we map it into
this example over here.
Okay.
So, now that we've stated that
we can now give our theorem on the
one-shot deviation principle.
So, let's consider
a multi-stage game.
We say for any strategy profile S star
the following are equivalent.
So, we're going to list some statements
about a strategy profile S star that are
equivalent. So, either all the
statements hold or none of the
statements hold.
So, the first statement is what we're
interested in.
It's that S star
is a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
So, this is what we're interested in.
You give me a strategy S star, a
strategy profile S star. We want to
understand is this strategy profile a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium?
Now, before we really do anything, let's
just understand the definition of a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium. So,
the first step is going to be pretty
easy. I just need to apply the
definition of a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium
to this specific multi-stage game.
So, we know that what does it mean for S
star to be a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium? It means in any subgame
the restriction of the strategy profile
to that subgame constitutes a Nash
equilibrium in that subgame.
But now, let's use our observation over
here about the structure of the
subgames.
So, instead of making a statement about
every subgame, we can make a statement
about every history. Because a subgame
is basically equivalent to a history.
So, we'll say
if and only if for every history H
well, what we want to say is that the
restriction of S star
to the H subgame
is a Nash equilibrium of the H subgame.
So, we'll say for every history H
S star H
is a Nash equilibrium
of
the H subgame.
Where what is the H subgame? This is
what I described up here. It's the
subgame that starts at history H where
the players have observed the path of
play along this history H up to the
current stage and then they can choose
how to behave from here onward.
What is S star H? This is notation for
the restriction
of S star
to the H subgame.
Remember we can't say that S star is a
Nash equilibrium of the of the H subgame
because S star is not a strategy profile
in the H subgame. It specifies play at
all these histories that may not be in
that subgame.
So, here we just focus on the part of S
star
or the part of the strategies in S star
that specify behavior within this
particular subgame. So, so far we
haven't really done anything, right? So
far we've just stated the definition of
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium in this
particular context where the class of
subgames has a certain structure.
Any question? I think this lecture could
be a little more abstract than some of
the other ones, so I want to check in.
Any
questions about this? About what any of
the words mean?
It's great if people come after class
and ask me, but if you ask me in class
you can help your
your classmates as well.
They might be confused, too. Yeah. What
is the difference between these two
statements? Oh, uh we're getting to the
real results later. So, this is just
preparation. So, uh yeah, if you think
this is obvious that's that's fine. Uh
it's basically
once you understand the definitions,
yeah, we haven't done much. So, the real
the heart of the theorem is going to be
three.
Um
So, we're again not going to do much in
in point three. We're just going to kind
of break down what it means
uh for S S star H to be a Nash
equilibrium of the H subgame.
So, this means that
for every history H, I'll just use this
no player
has a profitable
unilateral deviation
from S star H
in the H subgame.
>> So here I still haven't really done
anything.
I've just written out
the definition of Nash equilibrium. What
does it mean for S star H to be a Nash
equilibrium of the H subgame? It just
means that in the H subgame, no player
can profitably deviate unilaterally from
the strategy profile. If a player starts
at the strategy they're supposed to play
and they deviate to a different
strategy, that can't be profitable
within the subgame. Just the definition
of Nash equilibrium.
So what makes this a theorem and what
makes this hard is the final step. But I
just want to make clear kind of the
structure of this. So now we comes the
actual result.
And what it says is at every history
no player
has a profitable
unilateral
one-shot deviation
at history H.
One-shot deviation, maybe I'll say from
S star H
at history H in the H subgame.
So this is where the theorem comes in.
Up here we're just saying no player has
a profitable deviation of any kind. It
could be a really complicated deviation
where they deviate at many, many
histories.
Statement four says
in fact, no player has a profitable
one-shot deviation at history H. And
that means they're going to deviate
we're only considering deviations to
strategies that differ from their
equilibrium strategy exactly at history
H. And at every other history, it
specifies the same behavior.
So let's just understand
one direction of this
is easy.
So I think the equivalence of
one through three
one, two, and three are equivalent by
definition.
Right?
The equivalence of one and two
follows is just a statement about the
definition of subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium
and the structure of the subgames.
The equivalence of two and three is just
a statement of the definition of Nash
equilibrium. We're just breaking down
what it means for something to be a Nash
equilibrium. It means no player has a
profitable unilateral deviation.
And then
the implication from three to four
is also immediate. Why?
Why is this
immediate?
Yeah.
Because a one-shot deviation is a type
of unilateral deviation. Exactly. If no
deviation is profitable
if I already know that there's no
deviation that's profitable, well
certainly there can't be a profitable
one-shot deviation cuz that's just a
special kind of deviation.
So again, not a trick question, just
really easy.
If we know nothing is profitable, then
certainly this special kind of thing
can't be profitable, right? Just just
logic. So the heart of the theorem
which we're not even going to prove cuz
it's actually quite tricky, is four to
three. This is what's
uh
I don't know.
Hard, uh important, substantive I'll
say.
Because three to four is clear. If no
deviation is profitable, then clearly a
one-shot deviation can't be profitable.
But the other deviation the other
direction is not clear. Just because I
can't profit with a one-shot deviation,
how do I know that I can't profit with a
much more complicated deviation?
So the idea is if a simple deviation is
not profitable, where I'm using simple
colloquially then a complicated
deviation also can't be profitable.
Notice that was exactly the issue when
we talked here about complicated
deviations. We check We know We observed
that in the last class, we actually only
checked  simple deviations. We
didn't check that more complicated
deviations weren't profitable. But I
argued that intuitively, if the simple
deviations aren't profitable, then we
know that the more complicated ones
aren't profitable. And that's exactly
the same logic here, but it's just
mathematically a lot more tricky because
the game can possibly go on forever. But
the substantive idea is is still there.
Uh so we're not going to prove this.
Um
but
it's true.
And what it means is that it becomes
much easier to check
whether something is a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium. So given this theorem,
if I give you a strategy profile, say in
a quiz or an exam or in a game, and you
want to understand is this a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium, you don't have
to check that there's that no deviation
is profitable, you only have to worry
about the one-shot deviations. So you
can it allows you So what's the upshot?
The upshot is that to verify a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium
to verify that a strategy profile is an
SPNE, it's enough to check the one-shot
deviations.
That
one-shot deviations are not profitable.
Because if I know that the one-shot
deviations aren't profitable, the
theorem tells me that no deviations are
profitable and then I'm done.
Now that sounds nice.
We only have to check the one-shot
deviations but this is actually still
quite complicated because we have to
check the one-shot deviations still in
every
subgame. So checking one-shot deviations
may not be so hard, but notice we still
have the quantifier for every history.
So yes, we only have to check one-shot
deviations, but we have to check them at
every single history of the game.
And and in general doing this may be uh
kind of complicated.
Uh
I should maybe
be a little more precise.
I don't think this is, you know, big
issue this class, but um
and maybe this demonstrates that this
step four to three is not obvious. You
need one technical assumption for this
theorem to be true. So I said in in any
multi-stage game
I should really say in any multi-stage
game
uh
I should really say in any continuous
multi-stage game. We're not really going
to deal with discontinuous multi-stage
games in this class, but uh you can look
at the notes. I think they say a little
bit about the definition of continuous.
Continuous just means
if the game is infinite
if everyone plays exactly the same way a
billion periods into the game
then how they play beyond a billion
periods shouldn't have a big effect on
their payoffs.
So basically,
um
you know
if we if we want to understand what
people's payoffs are in the game, we
just have to look at how they play, say
a billion periods into the game, and
that'll give us a pretty good
approximation for what their payoffs
will be. It can't be that things, you
know, two trillion periods into the
future determine everything. So a
classic example of what will satisfy
this is if we just sum up the payoffs in
each period with a discount factor.
Because then things that happen really
far in the future get discounted a lot
and therefore they don't play much of a
role. But this is kind of a technical
thing that won't be covered in in this
class. Everything we study in this class
will be continuous, so you don't have to
worry about this, but I'm happy to talk
after uh if you have questions about
this.
Okay.
If you like math, I think this is a nice
theorem to think about and think about
how you would prove it, but that's not
going to be something we'll cover uh in
this class.
Okay, so now the question is how do we
use this theorem?
And
we're going to use this theorem to
analyze a classical game, just like we
talked about before, of price haggling,
but now with a potentially infinite
horizon.
So now we're going to look at maybe what
I'll call infinite
horizon
alternating offer bargain.
So let's just go through the words.
Let's start with alternating offer. This
is just like we talked about before, we
have two parties. They're negotiating or
bargaining. I'll use these terms
interchangeably over something. One term
One side comes to table, they say,
"Here's my proposal." The other side
says either great, we're done, or the
other side says, "No, I'm rejecting your
proposal. I'm going to come back with my
proposal."
Then the other side makes a proposal.
Now that can either be accepted or
rejected, and then we go again. And we
keep alternating our offers. You might
see this if you're at a used car
dealership, you might say, "I'll pay,
you know, 10,000 for the car." The
dealer says, "No, it's 15,000." You say,
"What about 12,000?" He says, "Oh, what
about 14,000?" And you kind of converge.
Infinite horizon means, well, we don't
literally think that negotiations will
go on forever, but there's no clear last
period. Whenever we're negotiating, it's
always possible that the offer can be
rejected and our negotiations or
bargaining could continue one more
period. So the infinite horizon allows
us to rule out these kind of weird last
period effects that we saw where we know
that this is our very last opportunity
to negotiate and whoever makes an offer
in that period has a lot of bargaining
power. So, we want to kind of shut down
that weird last period effect by saying,
in principle, there's no end date. The
negotiations could just be ongoing.
Um and we want a very abstract model of
this that can capture not just haggling
over the price of something, but also
say international relations. You know,
right now there's some negotiations
going on in the Middle East. How can we
have a very general model that can
capture these negotiations?
So, what we want to do
Well, that's hard because
what we're negotiating over may be very
complicated. So, maybe I'll say the
terms
of dispute
may be complicated.
So, how can we represent this? Well,
what's relevant to the parties is not
the details that we're negotiating over,
but the utilities we get from those
details.
So, we're going to reduce these
complicated terms to utilities.
We're going to reduce
to maybe utility space.
Now, of course, in reality, this is not
how we negotiate, but we might say,
instead of thinking of of terms of
negotiation as a 20-point plan
about the terms of some deal, we might
say, well, let's represent that 20-point
plan by the utility it gives to party
one and the utility it gives to party
two.
Now, of course, in reality, we don't say
this. We don't say, "Here's my offer.
You get utility seven and I get utility
three." No one actually speaks that way,
but what we're saying is the
strategically relevant aspect of the
terms of some offer is simply how much
utility each party gets.
And we can just treat the offers in
utility space. We can represent them by
the utilities they give to each party.
So, what we're going to say
is we're going to think of utility
space.
We have
player one's utility
and player two's utility.
And
the set of all possible agreements we
can reach we're simply going to
represent by the set of all possible
utility pairs we could get.
So, we're going to have some
set X. Let me draw it a very simple
example of a set, but we could be much
more general.
So, maybe this is our set X.
And this represents
feasible
utility pairs.
So, what do I mean by that? If you give
me some point in this set X, there
exists some agreement we could reach
that would generate these utilities for
the two sides.
What that agreement looks like, I'm not
taking a stand on. We're being very
abstract, but we just want to say it's
possible to achieve this.
And then if you give me a point out here
that's not in X, what I'm saying is
there is no agreement that could give
both sides this much utility. It would
be great if there was some deal that
makes us both really really happy, but
there's just nothing feasible uh that
would give us this utility.
And then the one more thing we have to
specify, well, negotiations can always
break down.
So, we have to say what happens if
negotiations break down and we don't
reach an agreement.
If we don't reach an agreement, maybe we
revert to the status quo. We have some
disagreement outcome.
But again, we want to reduce that
disagreement outcome also to utility
space. So, we often normalize it to the
origin, and this is going to be called
the disagreement point.
And what this says is if we don't reach
an agreement, something will happen. I
don't know exactly what that is, but uh
whatever it is, we can assign utility to
it.
And this is going to represent the
utilities we get if we don't reach an
agreement.
It's very standard to write our feasible
set X to lie above the disagreement
point.
Why is that? What if there was some
agreement we could make that would give
utilities over here?
I'm arguing that this is not going to be
so relevant to our negotiation. Let me
put one down here as well.
Why Why was is something like this some
point like this not really going to be
relevant to our negotiations? Yeah, in
the front. Why bargain at all if you can
just disagree and get better utilities?
And and I agree, but but for whom? I
would Let's be more specific. So,
uh
If we disagree, we don't both get better
utility. Who gets better utility in this
example? Disagreement. So, it would be
you two.
Uh Yes. So, what What I mean here is if
we both disagree,
so disagreement I I maybe I should be
more clear. If we disagree and we don't
reach a deal, this specifies utilities
that both of us get, right?
So, let's understand. This deal is great
for player two.
It's a lot better than the disagreement
point for player two.
The problem is that it's worse for
player one.
So, the idea is player one would never
accept something like this because
player one can just walk away from the
negotiating table, force the
disagreement point, and get this point
here. So, I should say, when we talk
about a disagreement point, there's kind
of an implicit assumption here that each
player has unilateral power to reach the
disagreement point. And this is usually
true in negotiations, right? Any side
can just say, "I'm done. I'm walking
away from the table."
And we go down here.
Okay, what about this point? Why Why
could we never agree on a point like
this?
Who would Who would veto that? Yeah.
Player two. Player two would veto that
because player two can get this much
utility by walking away from the table,
and down here they get a strictly lower
utility. So, maybe there's some feasible
things down here, but we usually don't
even include them cuz they're not
relevant to the game. So, what's
relevant
are the set of feasible utilities. They
have to be feasible, otherwise they're
certainly not relevant, and they deliver
utility that's weakly better than the
disagreement point for both players. So,
neither party would unilaterally reject
this agreement.
But the question is, where are we going
to be within here? Right? That's That's
sort of the the goal of the analysis to
understand what's going to happen.
In this game, I think it's pretty
intuitive. You might think that we'll be
somewhere along this this line here. It
seems kind of intuitive that we don't
want to throw away utility, but where? I
mean, player one player two would love
to be up here.
Player one would love to be down here,
and it's not clear where along this
frontier we're going to be.
Um
So, today we're going to analyze this
special case. We could look at an
arbitrary disagreement point and an
arbitrary feasible set X and analyze
that game.
We're going to look at the special case
described here.
Now, you might say
uh
you know, what does this represent? It
turns out this is exactly
price haggling,
this picture. This is exactly price
haggling
between a seller and a buyer,
where the buyer values the good at one.
Let's see why this represents that.
Okay?
What is our disagreement point
in price haggling? What can happen if
we're a buyer and a seller come together
and they haggle over the price? Well,
they can always just walk away and not
exchange, right? So, if there's no
exchange,
we each get utility zero. The buyer
doesn't get the good, they don't pay
anything. The seller doesn't get any
revenue, so we get utility zero, right?
And now I need to decide who's the
seller and the buyer. Let's say this is
the seller and this is the buyer.
What about this point over here?
So, this At this point, the seller gets
utility one
and the buyer gets utility zero. What
does this represent?
How could we in our simple price
haggling game, where we have value and
we have risk-neutral agents, get to this
point?
So, this is sort of the best thing for
the seller. Yeah? Uh the buyer paid the
max they were willing to pay. And and
how much they were willing to pay? Uh
one. One. So, this would be the case
where the buyer buys at a price of one.
So, if the buyer buys at a price of one,
the seller's revenue is one, so the
seller's utility is one.
The buyer's utility is zero because they
value the good at one, but they paid one
for it. So, what does it mean to value a
good at something? It means if you pay
that much for it, it's as if you don't
have it. Your utility is exactly the
same. So, the buyer's utility is zero,
right? What about up here?
How do we get to this point? Yeah? The
buyer got it for free. The buyer gets it
for free. So, here they exchange the
good at a price of zero.
The buyer's utility is one because they
get the good for value of one, but they
pay nothing.
And the seller's utility is zero because
they don't raise any revenue,
right?
Now, you can see we can then move along
this line as we vary the price between
zero and one.
As we vary the price between zero and
one, we're going to move along this line
here, right?
Now, I guess technically we can also get
in the shaded region. How would we get
in this
shaded region? I mean, this is a bit
strange. No one would really do this,
but what could we do?
Well, technically I could
as the buyer I could say pay you 80
cents for the good and then burn 10
cents and just throw it away.
We probably wouldn't get that, but uh
you know, often we want to think of this
as kind of a convex set. So, technically
we could always burn money and just
throw things away and and go down here.
We don't expect this will happen, but um
you know,
in the monetary context, this maybe
seems crazy, but you certainly see in
negotiations people are sometimes
willing to put forward proposals that
would harm both parties as a threat. So,
in the monetary context, maybe it
doesn't seem uh reasonable, but it's
important to think about uh
the the possibility of threats that hurt
both parties, and that's why we want to
fill this in.
Okay.
So, we've seen how this fits into our
example.
And now we just need to say a little be
a little more formal. So, we have
uh
if we get an agreement
X1, X2
in X.
Uh so, let's go back to the terms. Maybe
player one
I'm going to be a little more abstract.
We can think of this in the price
haggling context, but we'll be abstract
and just think about players one and
player two.
If we reach an agreement X1, X2, and X,
then
well, we think that player one will get
utility X1 and player two will get
utility X2, but we also want to
represent the cost of delay.
Delay is costly, right? So, suppose we
reach an agreement here at time T.
Where T
is going to go
0 1 2
on forever.
Then, the utilities are going to be
well, player one gets utility delta to
the T X1
and player two gets utility delta to the
T X2.
And here
where delta
0 is less than delta is less than one.
So, this is just like we had before. We
have a discount factor delta.
The later on that we reach an agreement,
the less utility each of us gets.
Um
and as time passes,
things get worse and worse for both of
us. If we make an agreement in period
zero, remember any number any non-zero
number to the zero is just one, right?
So, if we agree immediately in period
zero, we just get X1 and X2.
If we agree in period one, we get delta
X1 delta X2. If we agree in period 10,
we get delta to the 10 X1 delta to the
10 X2.
And again, delta is going to
parameterize our patience, right? So,
what happens if delta is very close to
one? What does that represent? Is that
patience or impatience?
That's Yeah.
Patience, right? If delta is close to
one, even if T is really large, it
doesn't hurt us very much.
If delta is close to zero, we're very
impatient and in the extreme case, if
delta is zero, then basically the world
ends tomorrow. And the only way we can
reach a deal is if we uh reach a deal in
the first period.
Okay, so this is our model.
Now, we have to specify the sequence
in which we
make offers.
And I think the standard way I will do
it is we have time
0 1 2 3 and so on.
And it's alternating offers, so let's
say that the
in the even periods,
player one makes an offer.
So, maybe I'll say makes an offer.
And then player two can either accept or
reject that offer.
And then in the odd periods, player two
is the one who moves.
Okay. So, just to be clear, player one
makes an offer.
If player two accepts that offer,
that's it. We we implement the offer and
we stop.
If player two rejects that offer, then
player two comes back and makes their
offer.
Player one can either accept or reject.
If they accept it, we make that offer
and we accept that offer and we stop. If
they reject it, we move on to the next
period and we go on like this.
Now, what is an offer though? Remember,
in our price haggling game, an offer was
a price. We said what price is offered.
But more generally, an offer is simply
a point in X.
Right? Remember, that's how we're going
to represent an offer. An offer is to
say, let's stop now. Let's reach this
agreement and let's get that utility.
So, let's be clear that an offer
is always a point in X.
I've specified the payoffs
if we reach an agreement X in time T.
And that's generally how the game will
end. At some time T, the offer will be
accepted. Some offer will be accepted.
And now we can write down what the
payoffs are. But I just have to be more
careful here. What happens if we just go
on forever and nothing is accepted?
That's one thing that could happen in
the game.
So, I need to specify what the utilities
are in that case. And if it's never
accepted,
well, then we just move to our
disagreement point, which in this case
is going to be 0 0.
Never accepted,
we go to our disagreement point.
And in this case, we'll say that utility
is 0 0.
Right? We have to specify that because
that's one thing that could happen in
the game. Yes. So, does this represent
that
because of like time decay, we're
heading towards 0 0 like asymptotically
or do we actually like hit the point 0
0?
>> [snorts]
>> Is Is it just like both people are like,
"Okay, let's give up. Disagree."?
Yeah, I think interpreting what
disagreement means in the infinite
horizon is a little tricky, right?
Because like when does it actually
happen? Um
Yeah, so
I think, you know, there's a few
different interpretations. I I wouldn't
maybe interpret
the disagreement point.
So, one
one interpretation
um
Yeah, I don't want to confuse things.
One interpretation could be in each
period, until we reach a deal, we just
get a flow utility of zero in that
period.
And then once we reach an agreement, we
get the agreement utility from that
period onward. And then we discount and
sum our utilities. That would be one
interpretation you could give. Um so,
it's like really our payoffs would be
like 0 0 0 0 and then once we
get reach an agreement of X here, then
we get that agreement utility X X X X
forever and then we do the average
discounted payoff from that. I don't
want to create complications, but if you
did that, it would reduce to this model.
So, that would maybe be one way of
thinking about it.
Um because you're right. If if things go
on forever, there's not like a point
where we say, "Oh, we've disagreed." It
just says, "Well, we didn't reach an
agreement today." and that just happens
forever. So, maybe it's better to think
of it in terms of flow payoffs. Yeah.
Um good question. Yeah.
Okay.
So, now we'd like to analyze this game.
We did the the whole one-shot deviation
principle to help us study games like
this. Um but it's not even clear that
this is a multi-stage game
because players are not moving
simultaneously.
Players are moving sequentially. Player
one makes an offer and then player two
observes this. So, why is this a
multi-stage game?
Well, it turns out it is a multi-stage
game, but it's just the stages are not
given by time.
So, technically,
this is stage zero. Player one is the
only player who moves. This is stage
one.
This is stage two. This is stage three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine. So,
it is a multi-stage game. The
multi-stage game just requires that
within each stage, a subset of players
move simultaneously. Well, in this game,
the subset who moves is just a single
player.
And the history of past players always
observed, so it's a multi-stage game.
So, we can now apply the one-shot
deviation principle to try to understand
subgame perfect Nash equilibria of this
game.
Now, just like with our finite case, the
strategies in this game are really
complicated, right? What is a strategy
for player two? It has to say, "Whatever
offer I'm I've given in in period zero,
will I accept or reject that?"
Then based on that history, what offer
will I make in period one for every
possible history of play there? And on
and on and on. So, it's going to have to
specify a complete contingent plan that
says what I will either accept or offer
at every history of past play.
That's going to be really really
complicated, but we're going to
hopefully be able to solve it and then
make a prediction about what's going to
happen.
Um any guesses? I guess before we really
get into it,
if we look at our agreement
space here, any intuition about where we
might end up
in terms of payoffs? So, what any any
predictions about what might happen? Uh
yeah.
I mean, just like looking at the graph,
over time that line will
Exactly.
Uh that's right. So, if we made an
agreement in the initial period, we
could that's the only way we can get on
this line, right? Uh and any intuition
about where we might end up? I mean,
we'll we'll analyze it, but um
what do you think might happen in this
game? Who's going to do better? Yeah.
Don't make a guess. It's fine. Yeah.
Well, my thought was like last time we
talked about how like this kind of
depended like on the fact that the
negotiation was finite, so like it would
get sped up because both knew that like
they had to reach an agreement quickly.
So, I feel like it's going to devolve a
little bit more. Okay. And maybe if it's
like infinite, then like maybe the first
person that has the offer has the
advantage. That's That's true. So, I
agree. Um
we we still have kind of
complete information here. So, we talked
about last time, one reason that we're
not going to see actually delay and
disagreement is that we all agree for
each offer exactly what utilities that
gives us. In reality, if you make a
peace proposal in a negotiating plan,
you don't know how much utility that's
going to give to the other side. So,
there's been a big assumption here and
that's actually going to be a reason why
we're going to see an agreement
initially.
And indeed, the first mover,
player one, is going to have an
advantage in this game because they have
the power of moving first. Uh and
indeed, there's going to be a bit of a
first mover advantage, so we're going to
end up along this line, but a little
closer to player one. And the more
impatient the players are, the closer
we're going to be to player one.
Because the more impatient the players
are, let's think of the extreme case
just before we get into the analysis. I
think this is good when you whenever you
approach a problem to try to think
through what might happen before you
formally analyze it. Is that a
question? Yeah. Yeah, go ahead. Does
this only apply if we assume both have
the same level of patience? Good. So,
I'm assuming
that they have the same level of
patience. A very natural extension of
the model would be to say they have
different discount factors and indeed,
that would change the results and there
may be a problem set on that or
the problem is that algebra gets quite
messy, so I often don't assign it, but
that's a a classic extension. Yes,
exactly.
Um
uh yes. Yeah, I mean, if delta were
zero, then they would just make whatever
deal.
Exactly. So so let's go get to that. So
let's say Delta is zero. So the world
ends after tomorrow. Player one is
making a proposal. What do you think
player one's going to propose and where
are we going to be on this triangle?
Yeah.
Right.
So we're basically maybe there's an
issue with like point one point oh one.
But we're basically going to be here,
right? So player one's going to have all
the power. If the game if the world ends
tomorrow, then you as player two have to
accept whatever I give you. So I'm going
to make an offer way down here. I'm
going to give you almost no utility and
we're going to be here.
And then intuitively as the as the
players become very very patient, well,
now the first mover advantage that
player one gets is going to shrink,
right? If we're very patient, the fact
that you might have to wait till
tomorrow isn't a big deal. And as we get
more and more patient, we're going to
move and we're going to converge to the
midpoint of here. Because as Delta goes
to one, the fact that player one moves
first is not really an advantage at all
and therefore we expect kind of the
symmetric solution where we end up here.
And that's exactly what we're going to
see, but that's just sort of a a
preview.
Yes. So that means we're never going to
be on the left side of the midpoint
where player two
That's correct. We are not because
player one moves first. So if player two
moves first, we would have the mirror
image. Where player two moves first and
and the discount factor were zero, we'd
be up here and then we would converge
down to here. So when we talk about
converge, do we actually hit the
midpoint or do we just get like
infinitely Uh in this case we will we
will not literally hit it. We will just
converge, yeah. We will get arbitrarily
close as Delta goes to one, yeah.
You cuz what would happen, you'd want to
say we hit it when Delta equals one.
Actually,
uh
if Delta equals one, we then have to be
a little more careful about Delta equals
one. So let's uh there could be multiple
equilibria. So let's not We're not going
to deal with the exact Delta equals one
case, yeah.
Um okay.
Great. So let's uh try to analyze this.
Let's go down here.
So as we said, specifying a strategy in
this game is really really complicated.
There's so many histories. But what
we're going to look for is a very very
simple strategy where people's behavior
doesn't really depend on the details of
the past. That basically when it's your
turn to propose,
you basically propose the same thing no
matter what else happened. And we're
going to check that this is an
equilibrium. So here's our conjectured
uh maybe our candidate
SPNE. So we'll check that this is
actually an SPNE.
Well, as we said, we think that the
whoever proposes, whatever history we're
at, has some advantage.
And what's going to happen is
at any history,
well, someone's the proposer. It's
either player one or player two
depending on whether it's an even
history or an odd history, but let's not
worry about that. At any history,
the proposer
proposes
Well, I'd like to use a vector in X, but
the problem is a vector in X tells me
the payoffs for player one and player
two. And the proposer could be player
one or player two. So I really want to
think in terms of whoever's proposing
and who's responding rather than the
actual labels of the players. So let's
say the proposer proposes
some utility for herself and some
utility for the other player, for the
respondent. So they're going to propose,
well, let's think. They're the proposer,
so they have the a bit more power. So we
think they're going to propose more than
half to themselves and less than half to
the other player.
And in fact, it's going to be exactly
and this is a a formula we saw in class
a few weeks ago, uh
one over one plus Delta.
Write it this way.
Maybe I'll say for herself.
And then Delta over one plus Delta
for opponent.
So I'm proposing I'm proposing a split.
Remember, if we look at this line,
along this line, the sum of the
components of this vector is always one.
So we're basically thinking how do we
split the one unit of utility we have.
And I'm going to propose to keep one
over one plus Delta for myself as the
proposer
and Delta over one plus Delta for the
opponent. Okay? Let's just understand
how this fits in with our intuition that
we said before.
If Delta gets very close to one,
then I'm basically proposing an even
split.
It's very close to half half.
If Delta gets very close to zero,
then I'm basically taking everything for
myself.
So this is comports with the intuition
that we presented.
So at any history, the proposer proposes
this. And
after any proposal, what does the
respondent do?
Remember, we can't just say what the
respondent does in response to this
proposal because we have to specify the
respondent's strategy at every history
including some proposals that we don't
expect to be actually be made.
So let's say the respondent
faces
some proposal,
any proposal,
maybe I'll say an arbitrary proposal.
And the intuition about, well,
certainly the respondent should accept
if they're offered enough
and reject otherwise.
So what is enough?
Accept if
It's always tricky with the notation. So
what I mean is accept if what's offered
to the respondent, the respondent's
component of that vector is large
enough.
Maybe I'll say accept if she gets
at least what?
So meaning there's some offer that's
made. The offer specifies utility for
both players. What the respondent cares
about is the utility that she's offered
and she gets at least what? What is sort
of the critical value she's going to
need to get?
Thoughts?
Well, in this equilibrium, the proposer
is giving this much to the other player.
So why are they giving the other player
this much?
That's the least they can give them that
they'll still accept, right? So it's
exactly going to be Delta over one plus
Delta.
So let's just understand the structure.
When I'm the proposer, I anticipate that
the other player, the respondent, will
only accept my offer if I offer to give
them at least this much utility.
So what am I going to do? Well, I could
give them more utility than this and
they'd accept it, but I don't want to do
that. That leaves less utility for me.
So I'm going to give them the smallest
amount of utility that they will
actually accept.
And this is going to be our strategy. So
remember, this specifies a lot. If we're
at some really complicated history,
whatever's happened, whoever's the
proposer is going to propose exactly
this split.
And if we're down here, whatever's
offered, the respondent is going to
follow up with exactly this strategy. So
this is a complete contingent plan in
the game. I didn't write it out really
mathematically, but it's capturing a lot
of complexity here.
Yes. So as long as the proposer proposes
this match in the first step, the game
is Exactly right. Which is exactly what
we found in the finite horizon game as
well. We said there's no disagreement,
there's no delay. We immediately end in
the first period and we immediately end
with these splits. And these splits
exactly correspond to the points along
the line that I was describing, right?
So if these strategies are followed,
then in the first period,
player one proposes this split and
therefore player one gets one over one
plus Delta. And as we said, if Delta is
close to zero, this converges to a half.
If Delta is close to Sorry, if Delta is
close to zero, this converges to one.
And if Delta converges to one, this
converges to a half. So it's exactly
uh what we talked about down here.
Okay. So now we want to verify
that this is
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
So what do we need to do?
We need to check that the proposer has
no profitable one-shot deviation and the
responder has no profitable one-shot
deviation.
So we need to check
no profitable
one-shot deviations.
So let's start with the proposer.
There's a few things they could do.
They could, let's say, offer the
responder more
than Delta over one plus Delta or they
could offer the responder
less than Delta over one plus Delta.
There's a lot of things they could do,
but let me just organize them in this
way.
So suppose I'm the proposer and I
deviate at a some history by offering
the respondent less
than Delta over one plus Delta. Well,
then what happens?
Well, according to the respondent's
strategy,
this offer is going to be rejected.
>> So if this offer is rejected,
what payoff am I going to get as the
proposer?
Well, today I'm the proposer.
I've proposed an offer that's been
rejected.
That means tomorrow the person who
rejected my offer is going to propose
something tomorrow,
and then I have to decide what to do.
But we're only looking at one shot
deviations.
So, if I'm the proposer, I'm only
deviating here. So once we get to
tomorrow, I'm going to follow the
strategy I'm supposed to follow.
So if I follow the strategy I'm supposed
to follow tomorrow, because that's what
a one shot deviation means,
then tomorrow, well, I'm going to be
offered
delta over one plus delta,
and I'm going to accept it. Because this
is if I didn't accept it, that would be
a multi-shot deviation, which we don't
have to worry about.
So it's going to be rejected.
So tomorrow,
I'm going to be offered
delta over one plus delta,
and I'm going to accept.
Notice the trickiness.
Whether I want to offer less than
delta over one plus delta to the other
player today, depends on how I'm going
to play in the rest of the game.
The one shot deviation principle allows
us to take as fixed how I'm going to
play in the rest of the game,
and focus on a very specific kind of
deviation, and it's easier to check that
this very specific deviation is not
profitable. There might be really
complicated deviations where I offer too
little today, then I also do something
weird tomorrow, then I do something
weird the next day, but we don't have to
worry about these by the one shot
deviation principle.
So what happens if tomorrow I'm offered
delta over one plus delta and I accept,
what is my discounted payoff going to
be?
Discounted into today's units, what will
my payoff be?
Well, I'm getting delta over one plus
delta tomorrow, but I have to discount
that back to today.
So today it's going to be delta times
that. So my payoff is going to be delta
squared over one plus delta.
But if I don't deviate,
I get one over one plus delta, so that's
certainly better.
So this deviation is not profitable.
It's strictly unprofitable.
What if I offer more than delta over one
plus delta to the other player? Can this
be profitable? What's going to happen?
Yeah. Well, the other player is going to
accept. Right? So it'll be accepted, and
then what? But is that good for me?
No, because now you're only getting
Now you're losing
R minus delta over one plus delta.
Exactly. So if I give the responder more
than delta over one plus delta,
I can't be getting more than one over
one plus delta, so this must be worse
than me worse for me.
And unprofitable.
So I haven't, you know, you can write
out all the math really carefully, but I
think it's better to just think through
kind of the story. So,
what are the two kinds of deviations
we're considering? We're considering one
shot deviations where the proposer
proposed a different offer today, but
then follows their equilibrium strategy
or their candidate equilibrium strategy
forever after.
One kind of deviation is a deviation
where they are very generous, and they
offer to give more to the other player.
The other player is going to accept this
offer, but I'm hurting myself as the
proposer by being too generous, more
generous than I need to be, so this
deviation won't be profitable.
Another thing I could do is I could
offer them less than what I'm supposed
to in equilibrium. I could be too
stingy.
If I'm too stingy, the offer will be
rejected.
That means tomorrow the other player
will make a counter offer to me.
The counter offer to me is going to be
delta over one plus delta,
but and
I'm going to accept it precisely because
this is a one shot deviation, and not
accepting it would be a multi-shot
deviation. But if I accept it, I
actually get a lower payoff and it's
farther in the future, which means it's
definitely worse for me.
So we've checked that the proposer does
not have any profitable one shot
deviations. We have not directly checked
multi-shot deviations where the proposer
is too stingy today, and then also
rejects the offer tomorrow, and then
does more complicated things, but the
one shot deviation principle says we
don't have to worry about that.
Any questions on that?
Okay.
Now let's look at the other side.
Let's look at the responder.
The responder
is offered some amount,
and
there's really kind of two cases.
So let's say the
responder is offered
at least, so we're going to split the
histories in two.
So there's some class of histories where
a lot of things happen, we don't worry
about it, but then at the end of it, I'm
the responder, and I'm offered some
amount that's weakly greater than delta
over one plus delta,
and what I'm supposed to do is accept
this.
And then there's other histories where
I'm offered strictly less than delta
over one plus delta, and again, I can
choose whether to accept or reject, but
I'm supposed to reject these.
And we need to check
that I don't have a profitable
deviation, a profitable one shot
deviation as the responder.
So,
when I'm offered
it's easy to compute what I get when I
accept these offers, right? So let's
write that down. If I'm offered more
than this and I accept, then I'm going
to get whatever this amount is that's
greater than or equal to delta over one
plus delta, and over here I'm going to
get this amount that's less than delta
over one plus delta.
Now the harder case is figuring out what
happens if I reject, because if I
reject, my payoff depends on what
happens tomorrow.
But again, we're only looking at one
shot deviations, so if I deviate here by
rejecting, we can consider what happens
tomorrow when I follow the strategy I'm
supposed to.
So if I reject as the responder,
tomorrow I become the proposer,
and now I follow my strategy. I propose
to keep one over one plus delta for
myself,
and give delta over one plus delta to
the other player, and the other player
has to accept, because that's what their
strategy says.
So then tomorrow,
I'm going to get
one over one plus delta
as the proposer.
But
that's going to be the discounted value
of that,
equals delta over one plus delta.
So one over over one plus delta tomorrow
is only worth delta times that to me
today,
but if I accept, I'm doing weakly better
than that. So this deviation is not
profitable. So we're good.
Uh let's look what happens if I
reject the offer. Well, we know if I
reject the offer, I'm going to become
the proposer, exactly the same argument
goes through. In fact, this is not even
a deviation. This is just saying what
happens if I follow my equilibrium
strategy and reject, I'm exactly going
to get
a discounted value of delta over one
plus delta.
And if I deviate and accept this offer,
I get strictly less than delta over one
plus delta, so again, it's not
profitable.
So we're good.
Let's just go through it. I think the
algebra can sometimes make it seem
harder than this, so let's try to
understand.
Suppose I'm offered an amount less than
delta over one plus delta.
My equilibrium strategy says I should
reject that offer,
propose the equilibrium split tomorrow,
and therefore get one over one plus
delta tomorrow, which has discounted
value delta over one plus delta.
If I deviate,
well, here we don't even have to worry
about whether it's a one shot deviation
or not, cuz if I deviate here, the game
ends immediately, and I get strictly
less than delta over one plus delta, so
my deviation is strictly unprofitable.
And now uh we've confirmed
that this constitutes a subgame perfect
Nash equilibrium,
and in fact, you can show that this is
the unique subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium, but that's a bit more
involved, and I might show it next
class.
Um
and I think I'm
perfectly out of time. So let me uh stop
there. Thanks.